Speaker 1: What are going to be looking at is
super concerning. There is a GOP candidate for
Senate in Missouri, Eric Greitens, who put
out a campaign ad and the whole ad. Is him
and a few other guys going rhino hunting. Which
Republican in name? Only rhino hunting. Now,
instead of just describing first how scary
and all this type of stuff this is. I'll
just go ahead and take a look at the video.
Speaker 2: GREITENS Navy SEAL. And today we're
going rhino hunting. The rhino feeds on corruption
and is marked by the stripes of cowardice.
Join the maggot crew. Get a rhino hunting
permit. There's no bagging limit. No tagging
limit. And it doesn't expire until.
Speaker 1: We save our country.
So I know at this point you've probably seen a lot
of campaign ads, particularly from Republicans,
that are promoting some level of violence.
But you can't allow yourself to get
numbed out to this type of terrible material. He
releases an ad where his entire premise is around
killing other Republicans, rhinos, Republicans in
name only. For what? Not being low, low enough for
Trump, which is usually their issue with people,
is they're not loyal enough and a big enough Trump
bootlegger. And there's not even a metaphor
there. I mean, it's not like a thinly veiled
threat of violence, though. He's just saying, you
know, rhinos, we say Republicans in name only.
Yeah, let's go hunt them. Let's go kill
them. That's the campaigner. That's it.
And literally, we're at the point where a
candidate for the United States Senate put out a
campaign ad that they think is going to help their
chances in the campaign or they want to put it out
and say, hey, everyone, all my followers, let's
go hunt people. Let's go hunt politicians. This is
so normal now somehow. I mean, we're covering
it. So it's not that normal. It's still crazy,
but it's way more normal than it
should be. And we've seen a number of
Republican ads that are candidates holding a
gun and talking about fighting the opposition
and all these other insinuations of
violence. But this is an escalation of
violence that I'm so afraid of. This type of
content that we're seeing become real common
is. It's not funny and it's not something
that should be overlooked, because as this
type of rhetoric escalates, the likelihood that
real world violence will be inflicted becomes
much more likely. And that's something that
I'm super, super afraid of for our country.